[Musique]
le plat que je vais préparer devant vous
s'appelle puncheur liège c'est le plat
national de la flandre maritime
surtout on peut on le fait dans un pot
ventru que l'on suspendait un à
crémaillère eux ça cuisez pendant deux
trois heures et on attendait qu'il soit
bien refroidi dans la gélatine et on
mange et on allait puiser un petit
morceau selon les besoins de la de la
maisonnée on peut mettre trop de viande
quatre si l'on veut mais en principe il
ya surtout les phrases les viandes base
le lapin et le veau alors on peut
ajouter du tout les mêmes du lard
seulement le lard c'est un peu gras
alors pour les petits estomacs vaut
mieux pas en tout cas c'est un plan un
plat qui n'est pas cher et pas difficile
à faire
tout le monde peut faire ça dès que vous
l'aurez vu vous aurez compris le lapin
que vous voyez là trois livres et c'est
les proportions qu'il faut pour une
place familial celui là a été levée à
zegerscappel avec du bon gras et ce sera
un délice que de manger ça du joug à
jarret de veau à peu près le même point
on met des échalotes du laurier du thym
du sel du poivre
en fait on couvre le tout de coin de
lave ont mais là-dessus vinaigre et au
en proportions égales
je commence par découper le jarret
on coupe des morceaux pas trop grand
pour pouvoir les caler entre les
morceaux du lapin de façon à ce que tout
le monde est un belge en longueur en
largeur
peu importe où vous étiez des morceaux
ceux là sont trop grands dont les coupe
en deux les facilités la cuisson
également on remet tout ça et si on bras
le lapin et on le découpe en tâche de
pas couper dans ses doigts et on fait
des beaux petits morceaux qui ravale nos
il faut presque de chirurgie en jeu sur
le côté les bras il est bien là soulier
vous serez ça fait fameux on découpe le
râble en petits morceaux
les couteaux reçu ce que les causes
jusqu'aux côtes
mais ça c'est trop gros alors être au
soleil à 3 pour le même un petit betsch
la tête coup le faut et aux coupes aussi
en petits morceaux et peu l'écoutent
bon alors quand la découpe et on se
trouve ici et on commence à ranger dans
les terrines un os lance du jarret ne
puisse pas réussi une petite goutte puis
ce pas là un morceau on survole petite
charlotte une petite échalotes dans là
dedans on va mettre en bourse ou
toujours comme ça et pour celui ci un
petit bout ici et du lapin de pâques du
vous doutez vous une petite échalotes et
une part un petit peu de thym de chaque
côté une petite feuille de laurier de ce
côté c'est un gros morceau pour un un
gros appétit c'est tout cela c'est pour
lui
seul par la pensée morale dont je
recommande tout garder ça maintenant
bien du sel puissant avec ses doigts un
du sable et du poids sur ce dur
[Rires]
voilà tout cela est en terminer en
liquide
on met les coins du rhin va te fuis au
cochon sévit
ça non et puis et ce sera terminé au
mess du bon sens que ça ne sèche pas et
pour aller au four alors hommes et un
verre donc mais ici j'ai eu mon boucher
m'a donné de la gélatine toutes faites
donc un verre de gélatine ici un verre
de génétine de l'autre côté un verre de
vinaigre parlant que ça se soit bien
passé
verre de vinaigre ayant placé ce dessin
il faut que ça baigne dans l'eau un
vinaigre
voilà voilà le potjevleesch terminée il
n'y a plus maintenant qu'à la mettre au
fond car les mettre au fond des terrines
et puis laisser cuire 3 heures
surveillez de temps en temps s'il n'y a
plus de liquide et remettre aux et
vinaigre et trois heures après peux vous
le sortez et le lendemain vous me fait
ça à froid et c'est absolument exquis il
y en a pour plusieurs jours si vous êtes
tout seul et on puise des petits
morceaux et si on veut on peut mettre du
saindoux dessus et sa garde très
longtemps maintenant on cuit le
potjevleesch dans le four à gaz mais ça
n'existait pas il n'y avait que soit
dans un gros pot ventru que l'on pendait
à la crémaillère ou bien alors dans le
four à pain pour qu' on puisse le cuir
le fera pas il fallait que ce soit un
jeune lapin par j'ai lu que l'humour
n'est ce pas et alors il était cuit très
vite parce que le four a pas c'est ce
sont des briques réfractaires
n'est ce pas qui donne le chaleur pour
le patient va très vite mais tout de
même pour le potjevleesch il faut que ça
il temps de cuire les pommes aux clients
remettaient les pommes de terre
dans la cendre et manger des pommes de
terre on les cas c'est comme ça à la
main et on mettait ça avec du beurre de
fermes et ça vous pour les gosses alors
que l'élan de la bouche et cela faisait
du bien les gens étaient mieux portants
que maintenant où il n'y a plus que des
choses falsifiés et des pommes de terre
traité il y avait surtout une grosse
variété de pomme de terre
moi je me rappelle que mon père nous
acheter des pommes de terre des rois
reines chez des pommes de terre rouge
il y avait des marjolaine il y avait des
pommes de terre exquise et maintenant il
n'y a plus qu un gabarit est une espèce
en a ceux des pommes de terre on n'a
plus le temps de choisir il ya fait la
pomme de terre que l'on mange avec du
poisson il y avait une pomme de terre
pour les frites et hervé la pomme de
terre spéciale pour mettre au four qui
n'étaient pas sains quand tu vois la
mettez au four
j'en ai qu'elle reste bien et on
appelait ça des pommes de terre en robe
des champs et non pas en robe de chambre
comme disent les gens c'était la vraie
on a lavé sommairement et on mangeait la
pelure qui m'ont dit qu'ils étaient
purifiée par le par le feu dans en
flandre les gens se réunissaient pour se
souhaiter la bonne année et homo c'est
donc le potjevleesch après qu'une
débarrasser la table on se tournait vers
le feu de bois et on racontait des
histoires
les flamands aimait beaucoup sa maman
qu'il n'y réaliste aimait beaucoup la
fontaine et les histoires les fables de
la fontaine était commentée et même on
faisait des petites allusions en flamand
dans leur sujet et on se disait aussi
des tas de proverbes tous plus savoureux
les uns que les autres
concernant évidemment le poteau liesse
ou bien la nourriture on buvait un bon
verre de bière de cette bonne bière
qu'on faisait dans le pays car les
les brasseurs étaient très nombreux dans
le pays un pays comme bayonne y avait
douze brasseur pour une population tout
de même pas importante et la bière en
acheter 100 dans des petits tonneaux et
ont tiré en faisant tirer dans des pots
en terre et la guerre rester là dedans
tu es très fraîche et voici le
potjevleesch il a misé au t3 heures nous
comparons le faisait ainsi bon appétit
[Musique]